bonjour et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors la pêche
manifestement est l'un des principaux
points de blocage entre londres et
bruxelles depuis le début des
négociations d'ailleurs quelle est la
position de chaque camp sur ce point
c'est clair que les royaume uni est tout
à fait dans son droit lorsqu'il réclame
le contrôle de ses eaux territoriales ou
plus exactement des zones de sa zone
d'exclusion maritime qui doit lui
permettre effectivement de reprendre
possession des territoires de pêche
qu'ils avaient de droit et donc sur ce
plan là le royaume uni est dans une
position de force
d'où la nécessité pour les européens
d'imaginer un minimum de concessions sur
ce plan là pour espérer avoir un accord
quel type de concession il faut il
fallait d'abord que les européens
surtout les pays qui pratiquent la pêche
en mer du nord et la pêche dans la
manche ainsi que dans l'atlantique que
ces pays-là s'accordent pour un nouveau
partage éventuel des zones de pêche qui
permettent finalement au royaume uni de
sortir d'une certaine manière satisfait
d'un éventuel accord mais il faut bien
comprendre qu'il y à trois problèmes qui
bloquent actuellement il ya le problème
de la pêche
il y as deuxième problème qui est la
surveillance de faire en sorte qu'il n'y
ait pas de distorsion de concurrence
dans l'accord futur de libre échange est
le troisième accord qui est important
observé c'est qu'elle sera les pratiques
de gouvernance qui seront acceptables
pour tous les partis et notamment cette
question fondamentale de savoir qui
réglera les distorsions en cas de
conflit est ce que c'est la cour
européenne de justice sur ces trois
points
c'est sur ces trois points que les
négociations doit se fermer sur la pêche
vous avez raison c'est vraiment un point
cardinal câble pour la pêche française
notamment
c'est absolument capitale de conserver
ses accès aux eaux britanniques
à votre avis est-ce qu'il ya une partie
à londres et est donc celle qui est trop
gourmand dans ces négociations
donc je crois que on a fait un petit
effort et
même si on considérait qu'il y ait
encore quelques semaines un accord était
quasiment impossible du fait que les
britanniques avaient créé une nouvelle
loi qui était en distorsion par rapport
aux accords de sortie qui avaient été
conclus auparavant
là visiblement on a continué à négocier
et on se rapproche de la possibilité
d'un accord donc si michel barnier a
demandé expressément aux partenaires de
l'union européenne et surtout des pays
qui pratiquent la pêche en mer du nord
de s'entendre sur d'éventuelles
concessions c'est précisément parce que
là visiblement on approche d'un accord
et puis aussi cette phrase de bruce
johnson qui lui tout à fait accepte
l'idée que les navires de pêche du
continent puisse continuer à pêcher dans
les eaux bobridge a dit qu'ils veulent
simplement qu'il y à un accord qui soit
à peu près qui table sur ce point donc
un accord est possible mais est ce que
un accord entre les pays européens
eux-mêmes pour le partage de la pêche de
jour je vous rappelle que en matière de
pêche est une affaire délicate c'est
qu'avec le réchauffement de la planète
tous les poissons émergent vers le nord
de la mer pour trouver des zones plus
favorable et donc le freinage se peur
vers le sud de la mer donc c'est sur ce
partage évolué dans le temps puisque les
poissons eux ne connaissent pas de
frontières c'est sur ce partage entre
les pays européens que la difficulté est
actuellement la plus grande mais on peut
espérer effectivement un accord mais les
négociations est difficile et on arrive
vraiment tout aux boules
et s'il n'y a pas d'accord non si on va
être pessimiste il n'y a pas d'accord
tient un odile quelles conséquences pour
les deux parties les conséquences
peuvent être terribles bien que les
partis s'y prépare mais cela veut bien
sûr dire que de nouveau la frontière est
totale entre les deux parties l'ex
europe large c'est à dire que ont établi
des droits de douane et d'une certaine
manière les eaux britanniques reviennent
intégralement au royaume uni ce qui bien
sûr laisse entrevoir des conflits qui
peuvent être sévères
d'une part aux frontières en matière de
l'application des réglementations doit
douane mais aussi
les zones de pêche où on a pas personne
n'a envie de voir se renouveler
des bagarres véritable bagarre sur les
eaux britanniques entre navires de pêche
des différents pays de l'europe
continentale et celle du royaume uni
françois poule et mathis merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes journaliste spécialiste de
l'union européenne merci